so jack harlow is the new star of white
men can't jump nice
and um
this is infuriating yeah i don't like it
why are you bothered because i wanted to
be that guy
i actually i actually want to play
wesley snipes you know how they like
flip every movie and they make like the
black version i want it to be the other
way i want to play wesley snipes and
then i want a black kid to grow up and
like be kind of like nerdy or whatever
and then he comes on and hustles how
many takes it would take for you to get
a dunk second how many i can't i can't
dunk no more yeah
he's about to i can't i used to be on a
dunk
foot mexican kid it was wow funny wait
where where was this we played pickup
one time and you just dunked on this
[ __ ] this little kid was so funny
yeah [ __ ] out of here little kid
yeah it is what it is when we on a court
everybody same age
uh but yeah so you know i i'm actually
i'm actually okay with this like i think
that jack harlow's kind of a
i'm excited for jack harlow because i
like jack harlow i like jack harlow he's
won me over but i don't know if he can
act and woody was so [ __ ] good
what is this he's the most underrated
actor maybe in my lifetime he's one of
the best actors in history yeah i got
three oscars i looked this up yeah dude
he can do comedy and drama yeah there's
only a handful of people that can do he
did [ __ ] cheers and true detective
yeah then he did mad movies white men
can't jump and then uh i think people
versus larry flynn he got best actor
he's a beast like he's a monster so he's
got to fill those shoes was going to be
very different that's the thing he's one
of the only two guys in hollywood
probably him and
maybe one other that looks better when
he's bald yeah like
he went bald and you're like yo being
bald is sick
yeah no he's the man bruce willis yeah
that's the other one
yeah bruce can work for bruce pull that
[ __ ] ball head off anyway yeah i'm
actually concerned with jack harlow
because it's just like dude you have
like big shoes that's my concern i don't
know if he can act like woody and woody
could hoop jack harlow seems like he can
hoop but like woody in that role is so
believable and so funny yeah he's like
vulnerable when he needs to be he's an
[ __ ] and he needs to be talk [ __ ]
when he needs to he's like perfect he
does everything knocks it out of the
party yeah and it's a campy movie and
sequels are campier so half the [ __ ]
goofiness will be the fact that what
does champion mean because i felt like
you just disrespected white men can't
jump yeah
like it's the the gags are kind of it's
like kind of goofy it's like
tongue-in-cheek a little bit what does
tongue-in-cheek
to know about this mean over here bro
you've never heard of camp no
it's like slightly ironic
no it wasn't
it was straightforward
i don't think you understand in 1992
that's how we all thought
you don't think any part of white man
can't jump is like kind of like supposed
to be it's well it's funny for starters
obviously but yeah yeah but it's funny
in like a like high-level humor i don't
do tongue-in-cheek this is real life bro
yeah
i don't do marketing do i ever do
tongue-in-cheek cause i don't know what
tongue-in-cheek is do you guys watch
like austin powers and you guys are like
there's there's no similarity between
awesome powers of white man can't do it
i'm picking an extreme campiness wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you got
like fat bastard like they were kind of
being extra silly with that costume you
go i thought they nailed it
yeah
there's parts i'm so confused me too i
don't know what's going on right now
okay well sequels of of movies like that
are always goofy okay like there's no
way that they're
casting jack harlow
they're trying to get you know nostalgia
it's a nostalgia play
mm-hmm yeah well we don't know yet
because it's a remake not a sequel
and so what is happening
y'all throwing a lot of terms around
yeah and i'm just trying to say what you
feel
me how do you know what camp shut the
[ __ ] up yeah i don't know what camp is
either bro camp
like
picture shows camp it's uh
sex in the city gas movie what you
talking about is sex in the city camp
can be
they're sometimes pretty it's like
a little bit a little bit bad boys camp
100 no what
what about the dark knight every action
movie is a little bit yes i feel like
every movie's camp mission impossible
what's not camp
mission possible not as much schindler's
list
i mean for me it was literally
if i'm not jacking off but literally a
little it really needs to be absurd
exactly it literally can
yeah
no so i think that what is that movie
that jonah hill and channing tatum redid
that was camp
in the way that they were satirizing the
original son you just throwing out more
terms i don't understand what the [ __ ]
is happening yo
i would say that's more just like
straight up are you confused i'm always
confused
hey
you know so you think that they're gonna
they're gonna 21 jump street
the new 21 jump street
white man i think it's going to be
someone like jack harlow probably is
going to want to play it really straight
i bet you the idea is it'll be a little
goofier i bet you a guy like jack
harlow's coming in to make this serious
this is his masterpiece probably
he thinks this is his eight mile
and it could be the director of this
movie right now finishing up their
remaking house party
so he's doing that who's in house party
what white rapper are they putting in
that movie to play kids
not sure
you